i have learned and changed you've
changed my life with hair i wear heat
protectant
now every day of my life
jonathan put his product on a piece of
toast put the toast in the toaster it
popped out everything was black and
charred except for the patch where his
product was was doughy pillowy soft
white untouched yeah so
and does in your hair like it does look
it's giving me shiny it's giving me and
you just you've come a long way i'm
really proud of you for that i'm really
proud of you for that it looks so good
it changed my hair
and i i so what is a good piece of
advice out there right now that we can
all learn i mean from jonathan van ness
about hair i will say not to like be my
own like pr person about the book but
love that story honey there is i put
this chapter or this essay in here it's
called tales from the salon and it's
literally
everything i learned from being behind
the chair also having my hair done like
because it's i've had such a interesting
like i was only behind the camera for 12
years and now i'm like on camera and i
like know how to do hair but sometimes i
gotta like trust somebody else to do it
and you're like
but you gotta keep that so really this
is like how to get how to invest in your
relationship with your hairdresser and
yourself and also i talk a lot about the
smoke and mirrors that the beauty
industry creates because like so often
when like someone's bringing in a photo
and they're like i want my hair to look
like this it's like honey there's like
thousands of dollars of extensions on
that head of hair there's also thousands
of dollars of photoshop color correction
lights so many lights picking up higher
hair doesn't even look like that yeah
exactly doesn't even look like that so
kind of level setting what these where
did we get these beauty expectations
from and realizing that like even so
much of what we're aspiring to be isn't
even real so let's celebrate where we
are let's let and and if you still want
to go for that go for it but it's like
just you're trying to get like that
ballpark like not exactly that picture
because that picture isn't even real
that's true and i'm so glad that you're
sharing it i'm a better person for you
being on the planet thank you
[Music]
i
i feel the love and i feel so much of
the support and i also like i do love to
share my healing i love to share where i
am um with people and it is cathartic
and healing for me and at the same time
i do feel this huge sense of
responsibility because
queer people lgbtqia plus people we are
dealing with so much in the world um
more specifically in this country there
is so much fear there's so much
transphobia there are so many kids that
are being like targeted there's so much
misinformation there's so much
fear-mongering and that hasn't changed
like that's been here since i was a
little little kid um and that fear of
like not knowing how to find myself not
knowing who i was thinking that there
was something wrong with me from my
earliest ages some of the times i
remember being bullied as a little kid i
remember thinking if i could ever do
something that could make it so that
other kids didn't have to go through
this i would do that
so this book is also about me giving
other young people and other people road
maps for healing and road maps for how
to contextualize a world around them
that doesn't leave a lot of clues it
doesn't stop with you i never know
what's coming next and it all works
together i love you so much i love you
thank you so much so much for coming and
promoting this beautiful beautiful book
love that story jonathan van ness
observations from a gorgeously queer
life and i love how much you talk about
messy and gorgeous too it's such a
strong theme in this book i relate not
to the gorgeous to the messy i love it
drew you are gorgeous
[Applause]
[Music]
you